jack was swimming deep underwater
wondering why he had such a pounding
headache when suddenly he had a
terrifying realization
he had no idea where he was or what he
was doing
there was a nagging feeling that he must
have a specific reason to be here
you don't just end up deep in the ocean
with a diving suit on by chance
yet he had no idea what he was supposed
to be doing
he wasn't sure he cared either he was
more worried about the throbbing pain in
his head and the vision of two eyes
staring at him
out of the dark that he couldn't get out
of his mind his heart began
to race as he wondered what to do and
how to get help he was in the middle of
the ocean and appeared to be all alone
he couldn't see anything in the dark
water except for this weird gray
substance in front of him
maybe he was going to die here alone
without knowing if anyone could even
hear him he began to speak aloud
about how he was consumed by sickness
and that darkness was all around him
this is the story of one of the most
powerful and dangerous anomalies yet
discovered
scp-3000 before jack's descent into
despair the scp
foundation had mandated an exploratory
expedition off the coast of bangladesh
after receiving a few strange reports
from locals and fishermen
the foundation suspected an scp was
lurking in the water
and positioned a few personnel to
investigate the crew
expected danger or maybe even death but
what they got instead
was far stranger and more ominous all of
the men had been verified to be in sound
mental states when the mission set out
but a few of them reported feeling
strange and uneasy as the submarine
descended into the ocean
before long a veteran agent named dr
williams began to panic in a way that
was completely out of character
he started sweating profusely shaking
and wouldn't listen to a word of comfort
or reason that anybody tried to offer
it might seem like a relatively normal
reaction for anyone descending into the
depths of the ocean
to meet with a monster that they don't
know anything about but dr williams was
a seasoned professional
who had been on hundreds of such
missions before there was no logical
reason for him to act like this
although the reaction of dr williams was
the most extreme he wasn't the only one
who started to feel strange
multiple agents developed a creeping
feeling of unease that swept over them
one of the calmer men tried to reason
with dr williams asking him what
was wrong and if he could explain
exactly how he was feeling
that's when things got even stranger not
only was the doctor
extremely anxious but he now seemed
incapable of giving a real response to
any questions thrown at him he could
only mutter that he was missing
something but he wasn't sure what
knowing that many scps can bend reality
and the human mind
many of the personnel began to have
second thoughts about the mission and
even asked for permission to call off
the mission
but they were mandated to continue so
they went on
as the team went deeper and deeper into
the ocean things only got worse
even the previously calm crew members
became spooked and antsy
while the ones who were already anxious
were now sweating and jittering
as for dr williams he was now pacing
back and forth around the submarine
saying things nobody could understand
every time he looked at his colleagues
and his close friends
he seemed to stare straight through them
and would call them by the wrong names
it was as if his mind had moved to a
different dimension
whenever someone asked him to perform
his normal duties he looked more
confused than ever
still the team went deeper dr williams
began to whimper and say the word
no repeatedly growing louder and louder
until he was screaming
and the others were forced to sedate him
just then something
came into view it was what would come to
be known as
scp-3000 the thing was huge
so huge that its whole body couldn't be
seen out of the submarine window
it was a horrible eel looking creature
with the head as big as a town
and haunting eyes that lit up the black
ocean around it but perhaps the
strangest part
was this giant eel seemed to be
producing a weird
gray liquid even the sedative wasn't
enough to keep dr williams calm anymore
there was
a strange blank look in his eyes as if
the light and life had left him
and he just began screaming no
repeatedly again and wouldn't respond to
any attempts to calm him down
not that anyone else was very capable of
calming him down at this point even the
crew members that had been holding up
well were starting to act
strangely and nobody could get the image
of these ominous eyes out of their heads
then things went from bad to worse
williams began screaming and shouting
madly as if he was being tortured by an
unseen force the men tried to restrain
him but it was no
use he began smashing his head against
the submarine window until it cracked
putting the whole mission in everyone's
life at risk he fell to the ground
injured chanting that there was nothing
whatever that meant
it was an emergency scenario they began
applying first aid to williams as the
submarine ascended to the surface as
quickly as possible before the pressure
of the ocean caused the cracked window
to explode
by the time they reached the surface
williams was dead but there was
something even more chilling than the
circumstances of his death
every single man who had been in that
submarine experienced the same thing
on the days that came afterwards the
image of the eel-like creature's eyes
seemed
burned in their minds permanently it
would haunt their waking hours for the
rest of their lives
and sleep was no escape either as they
would appear in both their dreams and
nightmares alike
forever a second mission had to be sent
to gather more information about the
strange beast
already there were many theories and
question marks surrounding scp-3000
how big was it really was it sentient
what was the liquid for
none of the men who had been on the
previous mission were willing to return
to the waters
but a new group of brave recruits
volunteered they were about to find out
what so many in history have learned
the hard way that bravery and
foolishness are often mistaken for the
same thing
this time the mission would not be in a
submarine but in dive suits in order to
observe the anomaly in even closer
detail
and to eliminate the chance of one team
member self-sabotaging the submarine
killing them all
they were transported to the location by
boat and the three men splashed into the
ocean
they descended and at first everything
was going well in case anything went
wrong the three of them were tethered
together for extra security but the
deeper into the ocean they swam and the
closer they got to scp-3000's location
they got
the stranger things became just like on
the last mission
first there were a few minor cases of
confusion one of the team
jack thought it was his responsibility
to lead the navigation
but another roberto also thought it was
his job in fact
navigation was actually the job of a
third team member amir
but he seemed to have forgotten everyone
was getting confused
the team listening in on the
conversations at the foundation
headquarters grew
increasingly concerned about what they
could hear was everyone losing their
minds
hopefully nobody was about to pull
another dr williams on them
still the project leads couldn't afford
to tell the men to come back to the
surface
the foundation badly needed any
information they could get on this scp
whatever the cost so they told the men
to press on things only got worse
roberto was asking to speak to a
colleague who passed away two years ago
while the others began to mutter
indistinguishable phrases
about eyes and darkness not too
dissimilar to the ramblings of dr
williams
it increasingly began to look like a
suicide mission
then there was silence what was going on
each of the men had completely
lost it to the point that they cut the
tether that was holding them together
all alone jack couldn't remember where
he was or why he was here
he desperately looked around to try and
gauge his surroundings but he could only
see
darkness all he could think about was a
pair of large eyes and an overwhelming
fear of despair and anxiety
and this weird gray fluid that was now
floating in front of him the foundation
listened as jack started reciting a
creepy speech about being on the edge of
nothing inches from oblivion with a
sickness in his mind and nothing but a
pair of eyes in front of him they
listened in horror as they heard
movement through
the radio it sounded like a huge
creature was swimming toward the men
it had to be scp-3000 but all three men
were too confused to do anything about
the situation
or to even see what was in front of them
claiming they couldn't see anything in
the darkness
there was silence for half a minute with
the team listening
in fearing the worst then they heard
some more unintelligible mutterings the
men must be alive but what on earth was
going on
then the gibberish started again two of
the men were screaming that jack had
just been swallowed
whole and that they were being sucked in
too why couldn't they just swim away
it was chaos but then a few moments
later roberto spoke into the radio
saying he was floating alone in the
middle of the ocean and had now moved
away from the eyes of scp-3000
he finally seemed capable of forming
coherent thoughts and speech
after what had just happened roberto now
had a theory he thought that somehow it
was impossible to think straight around
scp-3000 when he'd been close enough to
see the eyes roberto had felt a
throbbing pain in his brain
and been unable to think about anything
perhaps it was something to do with that
mysterious gray liquid
even more slime was coming out of
scp-3000 now
and roberto was determined to get a
sample despite the warnings from hq
in one final burst of motivation he swam
close enough to take some of the gray
liquid
and put it in a special sample
collection unit that was designed to
float to the surface for collection
later he had acquired some very
important data but he seemed to have
lost all hope of preserving his life
roberto started telling the team over
the radio that he was dying and that his
heart rate was too high
but cautioned that it would be too
dangerous for anyone to try and rescue
him the personnel continued to try and
communicate with roberto to figure out
what was going on
but his words had stopped making any
sense until finally he went quiet
minutes turned into hours hours into
days and still there was no sign of
roberto
or the rest of the divers after three
days his radio which had only been
sending a steady stream of static
finally stopped working altogether and
he was presumed dead
however the sample roberto had collected
had survived
and made it to the hands of the
foundation researchers it turned out to
be a viscous substance now known as
y-909
a chemical compound and extremely strong
anesthesia why 909 causes head pain
paranoia fear
panic memory loss and confusion
explaining what happened to dr williams
and the diving trio
the collection of y 909 might have
resulted in two disastrous missions but
there's a silver lining as the substance
ended up becoming an invaluable tool
for the scp foundation its ability to
make people forget what had just
happened to them can be used to
eliminate knowledge of threatening scps
among the public
it also helps the foundation staff cope
with the traumatic experiences they
encounter on their missions
although other amnestics can be used for
the same purpose none are as powerful as
the one produced by scp-3000
before its discovery the amnesics used
would break down too quickly
not farewell in storage or cause
undesirable side effects
the only problem is the method of
sourcing the only way to obtain why
909 is somewhat ethically questionable
for most people
scp-3000 produces y-909 after eating
so the best way to stock up on it is by
feeding the creature
sedated d-class personnel from the
foundation are sent on missions
supposedly to observe the anomaly up
close
unaware that this mission is one way
only other divers are then sent later to
collect the fluid from a safe distance
and store it
of course it's all for the greater good
of humanity now the foundation protects
scp-3000 as best as it can guard
something hundreds of kilometers long
the area is carefully patrolled and
members of the public are not allowed to
enter the part of the bay where it
resides
anybody who accidentally comes into
contact is contained
eventually another pair of foundation
doctors went down in the submarine to
try and learn more about scp-3000
one became so affected by why 909 that
he began hallucinating
he started talking about ananta sheisha
the king of serpents in hinduism
ananta shaisha is believed to be all
that will be left after the end of the
world
because it exists throughout all of
times simultaneously the doctor said he
believed that this was in fact ananta
sheisha
that scp-3000 simply shows us that
eventually
everyone dies and fades into the
darkness of oblivion right before he
exited the submarine and swam right into
his mouth
luckily for now scp-3000 seems to be in
a sort of hibernation state
it rarely moves and it doesn't hunt
although it will eat when fed
but no one knows when or if it'll wake
or what it's capable of if it does
will it destroy the world or simply
drive us all insane
you